okay hey everybody it's mike it's
about time to get started we've got
about 30 seconds to go but um you know
i said i'd start at four o'clock so i'm
just going to let the you know the the
late stragglers come on because we still
got about uh 30 seconds
but you know i see a lot of people uh i
see a lot of names i recognize
and you know again you know thanks for
supporting me over the years
and you know our products that we
release you know it's
there's a lot of uh tools for traders so
to speak out there on the market
and you know what we at order flows try
to do is you know provide
cutting edge forms of analysis you know
basically that
that um you know take information from
the order flow because
you know to be honest a lot of people
haven't really warmed up to order flow
and a great way to
get used to order flow is by having a
tool such as the flow shifts
so that being said um you know let's
let's jump into it so you know again you
know brief disclaimer please you know
everybody's here
we're professionals we're all adults in
the room you know we do realize markets
go up and go down
there is risk involved in the markets
you know markets don't always go up
um and and there was a great example of
you know a market that was under
pressure and rebounded right markets go
up and down so
just remember trading involves risk
okay so what i want to talk about today
is the order flows flow shifts you know
and
you know i don't really have a big
agenda on tap you know i don't want to
keep you guys here for
two hours or anything like that i just
want to give you guys a good overview
and show you how to use it today you
know tomorrow i have a special session
with pablo
from the indicator store pablo has his
tool called markers
which helps you automate
trade signals and i'm going to show you
how to use
flow shifts how to set it up with um
markers we're gonna do that tomorrow so
i'm not gonna
talk about automating it today that
that's tomorrow's topic
and you should already have an invite
for that
presentation but i'll be sending it out
later as well
so be sure to sign up for that if you're
interested in automating your trade
entry so today i'm gonna talk about what
is flow shifts
how to use flow shifts how flow shifts
differentia
is different from other indicators like
the flow scalper
and the pulse and uh i just sort of
talked about
automating flow shifts um with markers
and that's tomorrow then i'm going to
open it up for
questions and i'll do my best to give
you an answer
and you know over you know flow
really this is something that i've been
working on for quite a while
and you know it's gone through several
different iterations
over the last few years and
you know the reason for that
is because you know
the thing about working with
a programmer trying to get something
programmed into
an indicator especially in order flow
indicators
the programmer has to understand order
flow to a certain extent you know and i
have a great programmer
um that i use that i've been using
basically since i started
well not basically since i've started so
he sort
he understands it but even then you know
sometimes you know it's like i got to
explain to him sometimes you know no
this is how it's really supposed to be
looking at it because you know
i could give him a set of instructions
and you know as a simple programmer you
know if you've done any programming you
know you could just
program that in but then there's context
right there's
sort of market structure that you also
want to take into account
in in the
um what do you want to call it you know
it's sort of you know the whole trading
picture
okay so what i'll be talking about
is when flow shifts what it looks at
is the volume traded at the price right
how that volume traded
the price action of the bar the market
structure
and how the market is trading right now
okay because you know that that's
important on how the market is trading
now because yeah if
the market isn't conducive to sort of
your position yeah your position is not
going to
be very profitable okay so when i talk
about
let's just run through these you know
volume traded at the price obviously you
know that's the big thing about order
flow is
adding volume into the equation right as
opposed to just normally looking at a
normal
open high low close bar chart right
you're going to be looking at the volume
how it traded on the bid
how it traded on the offer where in the
bar
the volume traded was it near the bottom
or near the top
and you know depending on the type of
bar where that volume transacts is also
important
okay because you know you could have
your normal bar and generally
you know on a normal candlestick the
volume is
most likely going to be centered
somewhere in the middle when it starts
appearing you know at edges of the bars
that's where you know as a trader you
can find some value
in looking at the volume so you know
that deals with how it's traded
you know price action you know a lot of
people
come to order flow because you know
they're familiar with price action in
the market
okay and you know price action is
important you know is the market going
up you know is it going down are we
testing the high or testing low or about
the breakout
you know that sort of analysis also is
key in creating you know in setting up
an
indicator or a tool because you just
don't want to take an equation a simple
mathematical equation for example and
just plug it in and take every buy and
sell signal based off that equation
because if the conditions aren't there
you know with the surrounding rather
than just taking the answer okay two
plus two equals four
when in reality two plus two is is equal
to five you know based on
something else that's that's happening
okay and you know market structure
obviously you want to take into account
you know what's the structure of the
market you know
is the market weak or is it strong
and most importantly how the market is
trading now okay
if you're looking to get long you know
you want to be buying ideally
at a low price right if the market is
been rallying do you really want to keep
buying
at new highs all the time probably not
right you'd probably be looking for
an area that you know some weakness to
be coming into the market
that you can get short at right
and what makes flow shifts different
you know i left it out of this slide
here is that it the way i describe it
is long-term traders versus short-term
traders
long-term traders when they step into
the market you know they've got the big
deep pockets they're the ones that are
going to
help move the market in a direction
right they're going to stop a move
from you know that's been going on
they're going to stop that move and help
start
the other move ideally okay and you know
if a move is
underway the long-term trader joins in
that's going to give it an extra boost
right that's what you want to see
right you want to see the complementary
order flow but not just
volume by itself right you want to see a
certain type of volume
you want to see the big traders stepping
into the market
okay because the
people with the deep pockets right
they're not the ones that are going to
be getting out
quickly right they're not going to be
getting out oh you know in
eight hours right they're they're
they're looking to buy and keep it in
on their books and keep it as inventory
okay so you know what you really want to
see is
long-term participation as opposed to
short-term participation
in terms of the volume and for a lot of
people
that is a struggle to differentiate
because you know you just look at volume
right what trades on the exchanges now
everything is is pretty it's anonymous
honestly you can't come in there and say
yeah well this
you know this volume that traded is this
type of trader or you know
is the bank or you know is a hedge fund
but
obviously if you're watching the order
flow depending on how it traded
you could get a good idea right if that
money if that
volume has some strength behind it right
that's able to
arrest the move down or stop a move that
that's been going up
okay so you know that those are all sort
of the the little pieces that go into
flow shifts now
in using the flow shifts right there's
how do you really use it you want to be
using it for day trading right it's
it's not something that's really going
to be looking at to buy and hold for
um you know hold the position for a few
days
you know i mean you can hold the
position for a few hours
there's ways to use it for swing trading
but really you're not going to be
holding it from tuesday to thursday
all right you in and out preferably on
on the same day
and you know different markets you're
going to have
slightly different settings and you know
again not all markets trade exactly the
same
you know we like to think that right
everyone says well
um you know if you're using technical
analysis the same technical analysis
that works on the e-mini should work
on crude oil and that that should work
on ultra bonds and that should work on
the euro currency
well it should to a certain extent right
but obviously there's different
volume characteristics there's different
risk characteristics of each market
right every market doesn't trade the
same
right you have different market
participants that you have
in you know say the wheat market that
you different from what you have in the
euro currency market
okay so you have to take that into
account so while the settings
are in general mostly the same you know
you can tweak them to a particular
market as well as a particular
time frame right because you know you if
you're trading a one-minute chart you're
gonna be trading a one-minute chart
very different than you would trade a
four range chart you know in the e-minis
right or you trade a 30-second chart
in the micro nasdaq much different than
you would
trade you know a 10-range chart because
there's different volatility
profiles so to speak of different
markets and different chart types
and that's where you know these
different settings that i'm going to
just run through here
really quick you know help you balance
that out
right because again some markets move
faster than others so
obviously there's there's three things
here right
obviously the first is the license token
the second one is low volume markets
normal markets
and volatile markets this is the
detection levels right where
which type of market you're trading okay
so for example
if i was just trading e-minis on a
one-minute chart i would just use
low-volume markets and normal markets
originally
we had this called night session because
obviously the night session
is much lower volume than the day
session
but we we changed the name to low volume
market
because you know you would also apply it
on some of the slower markets
relative in terms of volume like say uh
wheat during the day
or um what else
you know a lot of the grains the oil
seeds um
you know some of the overseas markets as
well normal markets
pretty much all markets okay and
volatile markets volatile markets this
was really meant for
things like nasdaq mnq
um not
you can depending on which how you're
trading
certain markets like say ym or if you're
trading fdax
um you might want to try it with their i
use it for ultra bonds
as well uh so i know not with ultra
bonds um
i use it with i try and think of the
other market
maq dax
thank you why am i saying i was going
back and forth with it i think now i
have it off of my my ym
chart um but then obviously the the
swing filter but for most charts
you're going to use low volume markets
in normal markets okay
and i'm going to talk about the night
session when i get to the charts section
so the swing filter okay if you
want to find
new highs or new lows again you can
adjust that based on
how high or high low you know here
is one so if you have the swing filter
enabled you could enter
a period you know whether it's one bar
or 10 bars
et cetera and on some markets like mnq
you might want to have a higher
swing period you know as much as 10 or
even 20. minimum bar
volume now
for most markets it's not an issue
volume is not an issue
it's when you start getting into things
like the night session
okay where the volume just really drops
off
and in some markets it really just drops
off a cliff
during the day session you're not really
going to be worrying about the
bar volume but you know at night if
you're trading
you know mes or mnq you might want to
put a minimum bar volume
of 100 you know m
q probably 50 because when you're
analyzing volume you want some volume to
occur
right it's if there's not enough volume
and you get a signal sometimes
it's i don't say it's a weak signal but
it's a signal that's probably not
going to be very effective because the
volume it was just
low period okay so but again during the
day session that's not what you're not
going to have to worry about it
but at night you may want to consider it
i said
for a night for es you don't have to
worry about it
but during the the us day session you
definitely don't have to worry about it
but again
depending on the market you may want to
keep an eye on what the volume is like
at night
and understand your market now bar delta
confirmation and bar
delta divergence i like to use bar delta
confirmation meaning
if the bar is an
up bar it's got to have positive delta
if it's a down bar it's got to have
negative delta okay divergence would be
the opposite if it's an up bar
it would have to have negative delta or
if it's a dom bar would have to have
um positive delta it'd have to be a
divergence in the delta
and the bar direction okay now you could
disable both of them and it'll just
won't even take that into account you
just
unclick this bar delta confirmation
prominent poc confirmation um most
of you are don't need to use this it's
it's an extra filter
and it's really meant
for one or two users out there
that really like to look for primary
point of control the problem is with
prominent point of control
you really going to filter out a lot of
trades because not every every bar has a
point of control
not every bar has a prominent point of
control and during the trading day
you know unlike for example on a one
minute e-mini chart there might be only
15 prominent points of control that come
up so
you you turn that filter on with flow
shifts
you may get one two signals if that you
might get zero
but it's in there because i know some
people like to use that
as a filter now balance strength and
balance points now this is where
most of you guys are going to live in
here now balance strength
and balance points are different okay
and its balance strength is a value
between
one and five balance points is also
a value between one and five obviously
one is
the weakest so say you have a setting a
balanced strength of one and balance
points of one
that's the the lowest setting that can
be and you're gonna get a lot of signals
right now as you go up in strength
obviously
there's gonna be less signals right
because it's requiring
a stronger balance in the market or
to be to be happening basically and
high as you go is five um balance points
is similar the lowest the weakest one
is one the strongest is five and really
what it's looking for
are levels of balance
in the market okay one is the bare
minimum if it doesn't even
qualify to have one it's not gonna give
you a signal so
you can't you cannot enter zero it has
to be one
and um you know again five is the
highest
okay so it can't go over five so it
can't be it can't be zero so it's a
number it's a value between one and five
and it's just looking for these points
in the market
of balance okay and that's sort of how
the flow shifts are taking effect now
you can use you don't have to use the
same numbers you know it doesn't have to
be one and one or two and two
and three and three it doesn't have to
be three and one it could be one and
three you know one balance strength
um three balance points
you can adjust it right now i'm gonna
take you through some different markets
now
the last part i want to talk about is
the trade entry signal okay because
ultra bonds i don't use it on it's
pretty much the
one of two markets that i don't use it
on is ultra bonds
and a market that trades overseas that
nobody else is really interested in
and the reason being is
in a market like ultra bonds all right i
want to see the signals as soon as they
come up
right then i want to um take it from
there
okay so if i have trade entry signal
turned on what this means is
uh trade price level and ticks and trade
validity in bars is two and two
so that means that
after there's a bar with a signal
it has the next bar or two right trade
validity in bars is set to two
within the next two bars price has to
move in the direction of the signal by
two ticks okay and that
i've found right because you need
basically you need
follow-through order flow from
when you get into a trade once you get
into a trade there's nothing else you
can do as a trader
to make the market go in that direction
you're in
right i mean it's not like you you're
such a big player that you can keep
you know say you get long that you know
you want the market to go up that you
can keep buying
right because you can't right you're
just we're just small retail traders
we're not big
institutions or big you know trading
firms that we can just keep buying it
and help prop the price up and hopefully
other people will come in no you know
you and me you know i go out i buy my
two three contracts and that's it you
know then
it's okay yeah let the market go in my
direction so what the trade entry signal
does
is it tells me it tells
before it plots a signal right
it analyzes for the looks for the flow
shift right i have this on all my
my tools um it looks for the the shift
happening and once it happens
okay now it's getting ready right it can
plot a zone or could you know you could
turn that off
it's telling me hey you know what the
conditions are met here for this market
to start moving
okay and now when it comes into
getting into the trade if i have this
enabled right
within the next two bars the market has
to move
at least two ticks in that direction
because you know there's how many times
have you
bought something right you got into a
trade
and then the market immediately went the
opposite way you know you
you got long at 19. and we didn't even
trade 20.
next thing you know trading 18 17 16 and
you're just like
you know what the heck this keeps me out
of those trades where there's no
follow-through order flow and i use this
i said on
pretty much all the markets except ultra
bonds and palm oil okay
and again you know the reason why i
don't use it on ultra bonds and palm oil
is because you know that market trades a
little bit differently and i want to be
alert to whenever the signals here
okay and again that's that's me but
all the other markets i i use them on
okay so just you know before i jump into
the charts
how does this differentiate from you
know the flow scalper which i released
last year or the pulse which i released
two years ago
well again they read different
parts of the order flow right you know
order flow's got a lot of data
that a trader can use in their analysis
right you can
you know there's delta there's points of
control there's
imbalances you know there's a question
here i said i'd answer questions a
little bit later but you know there's a
question about
what is the prominent point of control
well it's a point of control
just really quick i'll get to the rest
of the questions later but this one sort
of applies here
what is a prominent point of control is
it's a point of control that matters
and what that means is it's a point of
control that acts as support or
resistance
in the market and it's it's a level that
i'm looking for the market to react to
you know starting immediately move away
or if it comes back to that level to act
as support
if it's a bullish prominent point of
control or
if it's a bearish primary point of
control um a level
that is going to act as resistance okay
so
you know that's what a prominent point
of control is and like i said
there's you know depending on on
the market and the chart type like i
said you know on an e-mini one-minute
chart there may be
you know from 8 30 to 3 o'clock
you know how many bars are there on a
on a one-minute chart you know it was 60
in an hour um
you know so what what is that three it's
like 330 bars
okay on a one minute chart during the
during the cash hours
but you know there might be 20 of those
prominent points of control right even
though there's a point of control on
every bar
not everyone is is a prominent point of
control but
flow scalper and pulse right so flow
shifts analyzes the volume traded at the
price
how it traded there how it traded in
relation to earlier how it's currently
trading right now
right because you know what's happening
right now is what's going to give you
the clues
um you know as to how the market's going
to trade next
right because you know as a scalper you
know
i don't like to necessarily define
myself as a scalper right i i
i've always defined myself as you know
what the market's moving i'm gonna get
in
get on get out you know sort of like
right in the elevator up a couple floors
and get out
so that's really you know that that's
my style training i'm not the type that
likes to i got enough stress in my life
with a lot of
other stuff i don't want to make trading
more stressful and i know how stressful
trading can be you know trust me i've
gotten calls in the middle of night when
i was you know working
on the trading desks you know saying hey
you know what we got this
position you know and we're out by six
figures
you know and i don't need that stress in
my life anymore so
my type of trading is has changed from
that right i don't want to
be going up and you know that's as sad
as it sounds
right i'm in the middle of a major
purchase
and i i was talking to somebody about
bitcoin
um because i sold some most all of my
um you know just like a week or two ago
and you know as i was joking i said you
know what you know
now when bitcoin's trading at you know
50 55 000
it can drop 5 000 10 000
in a day right imagine when bitcoin is
going to get up to
you know 200 000 i don't want to say a
million but you know imagine if bitcoin
is up at
200 000 right and it drops 10 percent
you know you're like oh you know
oh gosh it just bitcoin just dropped 25
today you know even though
you know it just gives you that extra
stress in your life because you're just
thinking you're just looking at the
number
um and you see it
right you know and you're sort of
internalizing it oh you know
that's that so that's how my trading is
now right my training is more short term
um more so than ever but flow scalper
right which is the one released last
year it analyzes the order flow to see
when the market is turning bullish
or bearish okay so it's looking at
different parts of the order flow
right i mean then the flow shifts
okay so that they're not based on the
same thing i'm going to show you on a
chart
the differences right between the two
signals
and pulse the pulse looks for areas
where
momentum starts to trade you know most
of trading revolves around momentum
and if you can pick up where
momentum happens as soon as it's
happening
then you know you can find yourself in a
trade
early that that's going to have a nice
run you know somebody
told me the other day they got you know
they they
just started using the pulse and they're
they're amazed you know they got like
200 ticks out of
the mnq you know literally on the second
or third day of
of using it so you know on markets that
trend a lot you know like like take for
example right
nasdaq today or mnq today right we had
that big run up from
um 700 you know around two o'clock
all the way up to what was it 850
so you know that's where they differ
they they look at different things of
the order flow right they don't look at
all the same things
right they flow shifts looks at
different
things than what flowscalper looked at
and
full scalper and flow shifts look at
different things than the pulse looked
at
okay so you know they all analyze
different things they're all
they're analyzing the order flow right
because there's not just one way to
trade order flow there's many different
ways
to look at order flow okay so
let's uh take a look now again tomorrow
we're going to do a special
tomorrow morning we got a special
presentation with pablo from the
indicator store and we're going to talk
about
automating flow shifts okay so you know
this is what i was talking about here in
nasdaq this afternoon right we had that
big run up here but
you know before i start going through a
bar chart let me um
[Music]
sort of talk about on a footprint chart
okay so this is ultra bonds okay
and just really quick you know
if you guys want my settings yeah i'm
fine i can give you my settings
um you know i've been sending out emails
with my settings
and you know it it's a good way you know
rather than sit here and try to figure
it out like my settings
again i'm going to i'm going to be
posting this recording
all right up later tonight but i'm going
to also i think i'll
just probably easier if i create a i'll
just screenshot all these
settings here for you so you know the
user guide has some settings but
again it might be easier rather than you
know having to email me
just to have you know a reference point
of
these different settings okay so
on this is what is this this is ultra
bonds on the footprint chart
okay um so for example
here right this area of ultra bonds like
i said ultra bonds is a great contract
to trade not a lot of people trade it
now it's
not meant for everybody okay takes
it trades 31.25 a tick and
it can move sometimes pretty quick okay
definitely you know no matter what
market you trade always have make sure
you got stops in
okay but just really quick here i'm
going to talk about this
area right here this was around 9 30 9
this morning right we went from the
183.08
um you know a nice move up you know
there's a nice quick 10 point move up
and 20 point move up
but you can see there's a lot of nice
signals especially if you're just trying
to scalp
three or four ticks in this market
so what it's looking at right let me uh
let me get this here so you can see let
me make this
lines a little bit stronger uh
crosshairs change it to
two okay
so here's a signal here here's a signal
here now again i have
trade entry signal off okay
and all right
where is it here trade entry signal is
disabled right on these other markets i
have it enabled
and really you know this is a market i
really have grown intimate with
and so that's why i turn it off okay so
if it was turned on it would not give
this signal here it would only give this
signal
because here's a signal but the next two
bars it didn't move
two ticks right this bar
there's a signal here and then the next
bar moved two ticks right here
right one two three right so the area
i'll be getting long in here is actually
at 16.
take a little bit heat down to 13 before
it popped up
but it's looking at obviously the
the delta of the bar it's looking at the
order flow
in the bar it's looking at
um you know what happened earlier again
i i
i i don't want to actually go into all
the details because
some of you guys you all get a bit bored
about what it's looking at but it's
looking at the
the order flow you know what's trading
on the bid what's traded on the offer
how it's trading on the bid how it's
trading on the offer
you know um imbalances yeah you know you
like to see obviously some buying
balances in a bar
um you know this one's got three this
one's got two but really
what it's looking at is combination of
how this volume is traded right
how this volume is traded okay and
that's important because
what you want right you want to have
good size volume go through and when you
have good size volume going through
in a bar you have better participation
right you can see some bars here right
look at this bar 624 contracts
okay there's a borrow seven contracts
there's a bar with 59
85 300 285 334 168 here's 424.
now i have the volume filter turned off
okay but
you know here's 423 and here's 526 there
are no signals there
so it's analyzing how this trading is
happening in the bar
you know making sure that it's
the type of traders that you want that
are going to help continue the move in
that direction
okay and
you know whether you're looking at you
know ultra bond chart now here's the
market just this bar just went sideways
right
it was a signal yeah it went up but then
it just literally went sideways for one
two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
bars
right and to be honest after about five
minutes of the market going sideways
that's not a good trade to be in right i
know some people say well you know what
the market can go
you know it's it can turn around and go
up right well it can just as easily turn
around and go down
i don't like to sit in a trade for you
know
five ten minutes with the market just
hanging around the open price
especially if you're coming right into
the cash open okay because you know
people could start dumping stocks or
whatever but nevertheless
you know as a trader and this doesn't
have to do with you know flow shifts or
full scalp or anything just being in a
trade
where it's just going sideways on you
just sort of burning your money
a whole you know not a hole in your
pocket but just burning your money up
and you know you're under water for
one two three four five minutes and
you're sort of hanging around
that's your opportunity to get out can i
turn around and go up yeah
but i like the trades that work out and
work out
quickly right i don't want to sit here
looking at my watch oh my gosh i've been
in this trade for
10 minutes it's not going anywhere right
that's not what you want
to be in a trade with right you want it
to
start happening sooner rather than later
okay
um you know he was a this was a buy
right here obviously it's taking into
account what's happening in this bar
also in relation to what was just
happening earlier
right it's kind of dead here right you
see the volume really starts to pick up
here
um why is volume pick up well sometimes
you know it's
means that there's more traders coming
in right it could be a big trader it
could be
a bunch of smaller bigger traders
and you know i don't want to say it's a
bunch of retail traders coming in but
you know you want to have healthy
participation
um in a bar right where you're getting a
signal
right um you know here's one it just
sort of went down a little bit
sideways you know but again you know
here's one
where it's it picked up and this was a
nice trade to have you know if you can
scalp out you know five six ticks you
know five ticks in the
um ultra bonds is 150 bucks right
so you know you want to have something
that is going to give you
signals you know good signals um
reliable signals
now how does this differ from
another market like uh crude oil
okay so this is crude today okay crude
you know just go back to the day session
here so my crude settings
are a bit different
okay so you can see here i'm just going
to show you now on a normal bar chart
it's a little easier to for some people
to digest
this crude chart i have literally set at
the basic the basic levels again right
now i'm
talking about one minute charts but you
know and i see there's a question in
there about
longer term charts which i'll address a
little bit later
but this is about as basic as you can
get low volume markets
normal markets i don't have volatile
markets for crude oil
i have no swing filter i do use delta
confirmation
honestly if you disable delta
confirmation you will get a few more
signals it's not like it's night or day
but if you use bar delta divergence
you're going to get a lot less signals
because that's asking for something
um where it's the opposite right where
you have
a an up bar with a negative delta or
down bar with positive delta but i have
balance strength
at one and balance points at one you
know on the ultra bond i had
balance strength at one and balance
points at
three i think it was
um where's my ultrabond chart all right
just show you the difference here
or so i balance strength at three and
balance points at one so
the opposite balance strength three
balance points one
but on crude right it's different right
because
crude trades differently than ultrabonds
right so
here you can see i'm just using balance
strength one
balance points one yeah i could change
it to the three
if you want to see what the difference
is right just take a look here
okay so this is set to um
one and one right you see a lot of
signals right and again i have the swing
filter turned off so it's going to give
me
um more signals if i have swing filter
turned on
it's going to take out this this this
this can take out a lot of these signals
right i like to use crude is a market
that i like to
um there's a lot of nice moves right
it doesn't look like sometimes there's
much moves on the chart but
on crude
30 40 cents there's a lot of those 30 40
cent moves
intraday in the crude okay so here i'm
turning
the filter or starting out the filter
the strength
to three um i should have showed you
before i clicked it but
um just so you get a
different uh perspective of the market
so just give it a second to come up here
um you know just
really quick some marshall
okay i'll check i'll check your thing
why you haven't gotten it okay so now
here right before i had balance strength
one right i changed it to three
there's still signals right but it's
just slightly less than before
okay i mean i prefer to have
one and one on crude but you know as you
start getting
into you know times like you know the
night session
um because i watch the night session a
lot
having the strength set at three
you're going to get less signals okay at
at night but i found you know during the
day and at the night
um overnight session it's it's fine um
to keep it at one and one in the crude
um i see ultra bonds i just talked about
you know on the footprint chart but
again you know ultra bonds
again it's a great market a lot of
people
don't necessarily follow it but um you
know everyone's all interested in mnq
they're interested in es
you know and i know people are
interested in m and q because there's a
lot of people posting on twitter
um their gains right and it's it's
it's seductive honestly but there's so
many other markets out there
right and ultrabonz is a great market to
to trade you know especially
at night right i mean you're not getting
many trades at night but you know this
is a move here
right i mean crosshairs
is a different color here
change you to black
but you know you know 24 up to 29
here it's five ticks again you know i'll
move from 29
to o2 03 right you know this one
okay you take the loss because stopped
you out fine
but you know you lose three four ticks
here but you got five here five there
you know it's it's a great market you
know he had a nice move here in the
ultra bonds and that's at the night
session right
look at these moves in the day session
on ultrabonds
yeah you're going to have there will be
trades that don't work out like this one
okay this one again you started to go
but then just went sideways on you um
this one started to go just one sideways
on you
you know at some point you know as a
trader you got to pull the trigger on
when to get out of a trade that's not
working out
okay so um i turned back here right
this is back to the crude right i put it
back on its original settings
just give you an idea right just when
you go back
you know you can see the night session
there was when i had the settings of
three and one there was less signals in
the night session
right it didn't catch this move here
down
um you know didn't catch this move up i
mean look at this on the night session
from six o'clock
58 70 you know went up to 58
90 pulled back back to 70 before going
all the way up to
you know what is that 25 30 right that's
the night session
right that's why we have you know this
extra filter for low volume markets you
know again originally i called it used
to call it night session
um but that's why i keep it on um
it's an extra sort of signal there i
mean you know it's a nice move here it
doesn't look like much but again this is
one of those
moves from 25 up to 65 you know
that's a 40 cent move again you know
nice signals here in the crude again
it's just using the basic one
but again you know you got to have your
stops in there right because sometimes
it's not going to give you
you know not every single trade is going
to be the winning trade
right now if i have this turned off this
swing filter let me just turn it off
here
again right now i have the swing filter
disabled
if i enable it okay just make this a
little bit smaller
in here okay so
you see these trades here this one this
one this one this one
um this one
maybe this one this one a lot of these
trades will disappear
right because there's essentially um
there's no swing filter this one will
disappear because
well this one will still appear i think
let's take a look
at the difference okay so just you know
again
why i have this the swing filter is
many markets i use it but there's some
markets where
you know there's just so many nice
little intraday moves
that i really want to be alerted to them
so
give it a second here to come up now
swing filter is set to one
if you're going to use the swing filter
the minimum setting is one
right you can't set it to zero you just
disable it
okay so you know all those shorts here
so here's the long down here um
again you know you have signal here here
you get stopped out okay fine
right you had to move here and you got a
nice little move down there
all right and so you're seeing again
you know a move from what 70 up to
the 30 right
you take a small loss a small loss a
small loss then boom
you get your 60 ticks there
all right um but again you know
that's what the swing felt that's the
difference on the swing filter
again and depending on how you trade
again you know it
is going to determine if you're going to
use the swing filter or not and the
market
now buns okay once this one
here i have both the flow scalper
and the flow shifts on the flow shifts
are
blue and red flow scalper
is green and orange
okay let me just try and make this so
you can see
there's not really very much overlap
right
flow scalper here flow shifts here flow
scalper flow scalper
then flow shifts full shifts
flow scalper flow scalper here right
flow scalper
here here here flow shifts here
right on this move up see there's
they're
analyzing different things you know
i don't want to say it will never be in
the same bar
because you know order flow's so dynamic
there is a chance that
you may have two signals at once and
honestly i've done some testing and
honestly what i like to look for is what
i call the groups the groupings
um of signals right like uh
you know two of flow shifts one a flow
scalper
all right together like that three and
two so to speak
um you know not sure if this bar had
them both on the same
one or if it's different by just one bar
here
right it looks like it's different by
one bar here but again you know i'm sort
of looking for those groupings
and sort of complement each other i'm
not looking for
you know sort of one and then the
opposite really if you see them grouped
together
you don't pay attention to them
again but you see they're they're coming
in at different points right
blue and red is flow shifts the
green and orange is flow scalper but
again you know this was just a basic
setting that i i threw on
you know i could adjust the setting um
i have just full scalper set at um what
is that
three and just basically three
right whereas the flow shifts i've got
three and one
and i'm using the
swing filter here i don't have the swing
filter right if i want to add a swing
filter
you know it's going to change how it
looks on the chart
right so i'm getting obviously a lot
less signals
all right this is mostly flow shifts
here full shifts
uh full scalper here the orange is the
flow scalper i'm not getting any buys on
this day
right until a little bit later in the
day
right here right you're starting to see
them both come in
so you know here these two are literally
almost the same bar but
they're just slightly different bars i
can tell just by how they're offset
but again that's the flow shifts and
photo scalper now this is mnq okay
now i i have two different charts here
i'll show you on mnq
these are both one minute charts but the
settings are slightly
different here
what is this one here
this one is my tighter one so it's swing
period of two
one and three balance points
this one has a swing filter of ten
three in one balance points right three
and one
this one is also um one and three so
it's the opposite there
one and three here you have a swing
filter of two
right this is a swing filter of
ten so it's really with a swing filter
of
10 right it's finding basically new lows
clear new lows
but you know areas that can be conceived
as turning points
right excuse me
i mean look at this move this this
afternoon two o'clock
right we had to move here three o'clock
or sorry one o'clock
um you know this was about a
40 point move doesn't look like much on
this chart because we have this big
gigantic move that came into new highs
late
in the day but you know it's a move
basically from whatever this
is here 720 all the way up to here
this is already 840 860 um
you know they're just going to make that
cleans up everything right here is a
move here
here was a move here here's a nice move
up here here's a little move down a
little move down
um this is just right around that cash
opening time
you know you always got to be careful um
around cash open
because the amount of volume that comes
in on the cash open
i don't say distorts the calculations
but all of a sudden you know you got
five times as much volume coming in on
the cash open that you're going to get
you know signals when you know it's a
time when you probably
really shouldn't be participating in the
market let the market
find its footing i'll give it a few
minutes to find its footing now this is
also m and q right but this time it's
set to a little bit quicker right swing
filter is set to two
but this time the balance shrinks and
balance points are
flipped right before it was three and
one now it's one and three now you're
seeing a lot of the same signals here
here um but the difference is you don't
have the cell signal here you don't have
a cell signal here
i don't think you had a buy signal here
on the other chart right
right here right so again you know
depending on how you set it up
and you know the market that you're
trading there's these slight differences
right
mini dao ym you know this was
now this chart is set to
a volatile markets low volume normal
markets
i have a swing period of one delta
confirmation i have on all my charts
excuse me balance strength is one
balance points is two
right trade entry signal is on so
you can see right again
this low you know up to here there's
actually
if i didn't have trade entry signal on
it would give me a short here
just as it gave me a short here and a
buy here some shorts here i can see you
can barely see these little zones being
drawn out
but the reason why you don't see any up
or down arrows is because
where is it here trade entry signal is
on you don't have the follow through
order flow so let me just make it a
little bit darker here so you can see it
a bit easier change that to 75 because
if the trade entry signal was off
then it's just gonna draw the arrow
every time there's a signal
okay but i use the trade entry signal
to tell me that you have that
follow-through order flow again you know
why would you take a trade
when there's no follow-through order
flow right because if they don't have
that if that's missing from the market
chances are the market's not going to
move in the direction that you want it
to move
right so
let's see here
close this so you can see here right
this red
this red this red this red trade entry
signal is on
but you don't have the actual trade
arrow right and that's important because
if you're using
markers you know which reads
that plot right that up or down triangle
that's what's being read by markers it's
not this zone this is just telling you
hey you know what
conditions are met in the order flow
that the signal would normally appear
here but now
it's waiting before it draws this arrow
right that's why you see that the
triangle rather it's not appearing on
the bar
with the zone drawn out right it's
appearing on the bar afterwards because
it's the bar afterwards that's
got the confirming order flow right so
imagine right if you're just trading the
signals blind right
and i don't recommend trading signals
blind in that sense
you know maybe you bought here if you
don't get stopped out on this little dip
right then you got something here right
or
if you sold this one right it rallied
back up a little bit before it sold off
here just sort of went sideways and
stopped you out here it just immediately
stopped you out obviously here stops you
out
but if you have the trade entry signal
on where's your
triangles here here here
right so you're not taking this this
trade you're not taking this trade or
this trade or this trade or this trade
you're taking this one you're taking
this one
you're taking this one right those are
the trades you want
right the trades that are going to have
the higher chance of winning
are the trades that have that follow
through order flow
right you want that order flow to
be in the direction of the move okay
because if it's not giving you that
that confirmation so to speak you know
if the other traders right
because what the flow shift did is is
it's read that bar
obviously in relation to everything else
that was going on and said you know what
the conditions there are met
right based on that on the order flow
that this is either bullish
or bearish right it's reading that this
is bullish here
okay what's happened here at this low
is bullish now all that's left to do is
have that confirmation that the market
is moving in your direction
right just as it said well you know what
we rallied up here
okay but and now it's bearish but
over the next two bars while the
conditions in the signal bar
are are bearish the next two bars you
still got a little bit of buying
pressure left
right and if you get short
you know and you have a stop just you
know somewhere behind this area you're
stopped out you just took a loss
right you want the trades that are
working
now all right going in the sense that
the order flow is there
to confirm it right that it's that it's
moving in your direction
okay so obviously you know you could see
you know
you don't want to be short here you know
especially if a market like today right
was just
it just picked up a big head of steam
and just
moved right there's nothing stopping
this move today
right you try to short your killed right
but the trade entry signal
told you you know you get long because
the conditions are met right the
sort of the the longer term traders are
getting involved down here
you know in here in here
and you know as the market's rallying
you know maybe it's people
trying to get out you know take some
profits because you know what this
market
was rallying it's not uncommon for
traders to take profits on
a rally in market okay but
market just kept going kept going kept
going right
you know here's a nice move here here's
a little move here but again you would
have been long from down here
again this is the cash open time um
right in here obviously things are
different in the night session here
you get some smaller moves
it doesn't doesn't look like much but
you know it's a move from whatever this
is
you know 40 all the way up to 70.
um here's a move but the trade entry
signal didn't kick off right that's why
you have no triangle here
this was a move trade entry signal was
is turned on so it didn't give you a buy
it didn't give you the
the red down triangle there right here's
a couple buys here now this is a two in
the morning
right most people if you're living in
europe or asia
you could be trading at that time all
right you don't need to wait till
the u.s hours open up this was a
short here but yeah we were just already
selling off
again didn't go lower yeah it went lower
about 10 15 ticks
um last night six o'clock 607
boom look at that so move from whatever
price this is 31
to 33 you know anywhere here
right because this is the signal bar
right here this one
right see 26 is the high as long as it
trades 28
it's telling you you want to participate
get long anywhere above 28th
and above you know all the way up to 80.
i'm not saying you would have sold right
up here but you know you're getting long
at 30
you know you'll be happy you know at six
o'clock at night you know you're happy
to sell at 60 it's a quick 30 points
um this was yesterday again you know
some nice moves
down a nice move up again this one
you just get stopped out you know but
again trade entry signal keeps you out
of this trade out of this trade out of
this trade
right that's why i have the trade entry
signal put in there
right you take this trade you take your
loss okay
um you know you get short again you get
it back
um you know again just some signals in
the night session here
you know this one you know
didn't work out then depending on where
you have your stop if you have a 10
point stop you don't get stopped out
yet you know when it rallies up from
whatever this is
27 up to up into the 40s but this one
failed
okay but you had a nice trade right here
right from 41. this is at
10 o'clock two days ago
right from 40 all the way down to 10.
right again you know just go back i mean
you can see these signals
okay you know move down
and move up right there's not many
signals on this day
i mean there's some nice signals down
here earlier but um
you know on this day mark it was under
some pressure late
some selling signals came in now
e-minis again this one is set to
pretty quick i think yeah
swing filter in this case is turned off
this one is all on
low volume markets normal markets
volatile markets balance strikes set to
one and two
e-minis is a great market to trade
obviously at night
it trades a lot of volume all right look
at this from last night
and the reopen all right they caught
that move up caught that move down
right um go back
i mean obviously the day before
a lot of nice signals i mean today
with the you know there's a lot of back
and forth action today
you know there's some good moves to be
had but
um the thing with e-minis you know it's
the biggest contract
out there in terms of volume that's
meaningful
and you know i just find it a little bit
easier to trade some of these
smaller markets i mean there's a lot of
nice moves to be had you know i know
guys are using the software they're just
their target is two ticks our xy92 takes
two points
eight ticks um you know and they do it
over and over
but i mean really you know i like the
fish where
there's not a lot of people fishing so
to speak you know i like to look
at the early morning you know the
european hours or um even
the asian hours right for opportunities
because there's a lot of nice
opportunities to be had
um during that time when sort of the
you know not competing against
the entire world right the amount of
volume that goes through in the night
session is
um you know about a third of what the
volume is during the day
but you know what if i could catch a
move or two in the night session it's
been a good night right it doesn't have
to be
a 10-point move you know a two-point
move here a point move there
you know all that stuff adds up right
again this one is set kind of loose
um because i got volatile markets on
i've got swing filter off and i got the
balance strength set at almost the
lowest
balance points you know set at the
lowest but again if i
you know even set that balance points to
one
you know it's going to give you
something else i'll show you what let me
tighten it up you know
i'll set it to three and three just give
you an example
um three and three is i think three and
two is the default settings but three
and three is
not normal strength but it's
a bit strong okay so i'm gonna you're
gonna see
less signals
so just give it a second here so you
know tomorrow like i said
tomorrow we got a special presentation
with pablo
from the indicator store and talking
about how you can
automate this tool or any other my tools
with markers right and that's incredibly
helpful for a lot of people that
will want to be trading at the night
session and don't want to be sitting in
front of a computer
or you know during the day session
you know trying to enter trades you know
thinking oh do i take it do i not take
it let the computer do that for you
um and do that so yeah once this comes
up give it a second here let's go take a
look at some quick questions here
um guido uh asks
let me see here this question
can you please comment from the overflow
point of view today's chart image which
i'm attaching with delta
um okay hold on let me see your
link here if i can click it because he's
asking me about a specific
chart um
come up
highlighted circles are the most
interesting points i would like to hear
your comments on
um okay all right let me
just talk about this chart here this
e-mini chart real quick so again
now i've set it to three and three right
and you can see the signals here
again it's um a lot less signals
all right the trade entry signal is
turned on all right so it's not giving
you this buy here this buy here
it's giving you this one right it's
giving you the the order flow
you know letting the order flow um
continue in that direction so you got
this short you got this short you got
this short
right all right because the order flow
is
confirming right you got this long you
got this long
you know you got this long that just
sort of went up and then just went
sideways
um but again it's a stricter setting
right so you got this long
you got this short you got this little
short here so
again you know depending on the setting
depending on the market um
you got to find your sweet spot
depending on how you trade
okay so you know tim asks
a question here what's a good setting
for an e-mini one-minute chart
well and depends on on you and your risk
tolerance
you know i suggest you know starting at
the standard
three and two which i think is the the
default right let's uh
what's the default here whoops that's
full scalper um
close shifts all right three and two one
right this is the default i'll take off
the
one that i was using just now
give it a chance um this is good for
scalping yes that's the question
um payment asked
all right so while that's coming up here
there's a question about
this chart
uh what does he say at this link you can
use for downloading highlighted circles
are the most interesting points i would
like to hear your comments
about uh
what okay it's a seven range
um we know if you're still in there what
time is this is this you i mean like
chicago time or
well this is probably okay this is
you're probably like gmt or something um
because i think this is the close right
here
right um because it says march 29th so
that would be
monday already but this area this area
well let's pull it up this is seven
range chart
let's pull up seven range i don't have
seven range on here i got eight range
but uh
let's add a seven range
seven
okay
okay i gotta change this one here to
seven
all right um well it's coming up let me
see some other questions here
i went to the of website twitter flow's
website you see this available on
ninjatrader never used ninjatrader
before
don't know whether the nt costs money
yeah you know
ninjatrader
ninjatrader it costs money but this will
run on the free version of ninjatrader
and so as long as you have a data feed
all right you can use the free version
of ninjatrader okay
obviously you're gonna want a real-time
data feed
okay so you still gotta pay for that
honestly what the best way to get a
cheap data feed is
you download the software throw in a
couple hundred bucks into the account
and tell them you want the data feed
right so you get the discounted data
feed
um you know i've got paid versions
that i use um as well as you know on
others like on this computer this is
sort of my testing computer or like my
backup computer
that i do a lot of other things on it's
not my trading computer right this is my
computer for emails and all sorts of
stuff
that uh yeah
i'm running in on the free version on
this pc but my trading pc obviously is
the paid version
if you're going to trade and you're
going to have an account with
ninjatrader
you're just better off getting the the
the paid version and you have to be
honest they always run these offers
every once in a while
where instead of 10.99 you can get it
for
9.99 or something like that
but it'll run on the free version i have
people that use the software they use
the free version and they just enter
their trades through
um their broker supplied front end which
is usually like
sierra charts or some modified zero
charge version that they have a white
label for
so it'll run on the free version or run
on the paid version but again if you're
trading
you're better off just upgrading to
the paid version of ninjatrader okay
because
it unlocks certain features um things
like
well i'll say advanced charting but what
is it things like this right this is
the things that you're going to want to
use right you're going to want to use
atm strategies right that's big right
because as soon as you enter a trade you
should
you can have stuff programmed in there
so it's going to enter your take profit
and your stop loss
you know obviously you can enter ocos
things like that for trade entry
you're definitely going to want to have
that
okay so i assume this is
on that chart it's by these circled
areas okay so now this is set to
these are the standard defaults right
this is
three and two
my other chart i had one and two i think
i had swing filter turned off i'm
curious to see what it's gonna look like
on a seven range chart honestly i don't
use a seven range chart
i used to use four range chart in eight
range charts
before trump became president because
the markets uh
were a bit more orderly and problem
on a range based charts is you could put
in a lot of bars
very quickly okay and
by the time you get in the market's
already moved
and i just found it a little bit saner
to use
a time based chart as opposed to a range
based chart but again you know
you could you could use a full range
chart you could use an eight range chart
you could use a seven range chart you
could use volume based charts
right i'll pull up a volume base chart
you know after this
um james would order flow three be
better
well you know the question i get a lot
is you know sometimes people buy
like this this uh full shifts and
they're thinking they're getting a
footprint chart no you're not you're
getting an indicator which will run on a
footprint chart or
a bar chart right honestly
i think order flows 3.0 is
is better because you're
forcing yourself to read the market and
understand it now
i use indicators for my own trading
because
there's really you know if you're
looking at
you know the order flow unless you know
you're familiar with the market and the
order flow
it can be not not tricky not deceiving
but it's a lot to digest
right it's a lot of information right
are you going to know to buy
this bar right are you going to know to
sell up here
and especially on a market that's you
know this is ultra bonds but you know if
you go to a market that's
you know a bit slower or sorry um that
moves differently
you know trades a lot of volume and you
start seeing a lot of trades
you know because obviously you know if
you trade something like
um wheat then you go and you trade
something like
uh you know e-minis or mnq or something
the markets move very differently all
right so
honestly i think it's
if you really want to understand the
markets right because again
flow shifts flow scalper pulse they just
read three different things about the
order flow
okay and i said unless you know what
you're looking at
it's going to be you know
looking at a footprint chart it's going
to change your trading right see
there's a learning curve right and
that's why i create indicators so
people can you know use
the indicator and sort of follow along
and start to understand why something's
happening
in the markets okay because
you know if you don't understand well
why is this market moving so quickly
well it's because you know one it could
be
lack of volume or two it could be a big
buyer or three it could be like a market
sweep right here
you you're not gonna be able to put it
together quickly enough and that's worse
having a tool like an indicator
is going to help you right like here
right market rallied up right boom
rallied up came off a little bit
and then you're seeing the nice big
buying
come back in here right and the market
made another move back up
right just as um you know here on the
on this way down it was a buy signal
here there was a sell signal there
right i like to look at the footprint
chart to help me manage a trade
all right you know i get in based on you
know flow scalper
or shifts or pulse or something i still
have to manage that trade i'm not
somebody that's
you know i like it when a trade goes to
my profit target
but i don't necessarily like it when it
goes directly to my stop
right if i see something in the order
flow
right you say i'm short here right at 15
right off this bar okay right in here
and i got to take profit at 05 right 10
point take profit right which is down
here right off this chart
right 05 is down here and then i see the
market moving yeah
this is great all right then it starts
to turn around
right i'm short from here 14 15 rather
and i see this bar with you know all
this aggressive buying coming in
i'm thinking you know i missed my
opportunity here at 05
also i see all this aggressive buying
coming in that's my sign to get out i'm
not going to
wait till you know it takes me out at
break even or or worse
you know stops me out at a loss right
reading the order flow
it's going to help you manage your trade
but again you know
it's it tools like flow shifts you know
are there to help you
understand hey you know what there's
something happening here in the order
flow that's that's bearish okay i can
get short
all right but then if i notice things
are changing down here
it's time for me to get out no shame in
getting out
you know if you're reading the order
flow and you realize conditions changed
in the market
now i started going back to this
7 range right again i had the default
setting up there earlier
but now i changed it to my sort of my
preferred setting right swing filter off
because if you're using a range based
chart all right you're probably going to
want to have
swing filter off okay and one and two
right one strength
two balance points i i can even use two
and two
it's not gonna be that big a difference
but
this was that first circle that you had
this was the second circle that you had
right obviously the market moved up i
have
the trade entry signal turned on that's
why there's
this buy didn't trigger here this cell
didn't trigger here
but you know this was the day in the
e-minis
right and again you know the thing with
a range based chart is a seven
range chart
all right this if a market is moving
very fast you're going to put in a lot
of bars it's not something you
necessarily notice so much in
e-minis especially on the seven range
sharp if you're using a four-range chart
you have a lot of bars in here
right if you're using a seven ring you
know i wouldn't even use a seven range
on m and q
if you're using nasdaq right and you got
a
ten point ten range chart you can have
you know some of these bars here i mean
look at this
right for example this bar right here
this bar on
mnq
right this you're talking you know five
and a half
all the way up to you know 30
30 and a half 30 and a quarter you say
29 and a half
so 29 and a half to five and a half what
is that that's over
you know it's a 24 point range in one
bar so imagine if you're using
um you know a 10 range
a 10 range um chart on m and q
you know yeah i mean in this one bar
you've got what four bars
all right so just bear that in mind um
you know james asks about you know
packages
well if you pick up flow scalper takes
you to a page to get you
the other ones a slightly cheaper price
can you show how you use balance
strength on the footprints
um
well it's it's yeah i mean i can try
i don't know if people will understand
it because
it's kind of complicated actually but um
you have balance in a bar right and you
have balance
over what just happened all right so you
get
different balance points okay and you
know sometimes the market is in balance
and sometimes it's out of balance it's
when the market
wants to start moving
out of balance right that's when um
the moves happen right because the
market's going to move from balance to
balance
so to speak it's going to move out from
a balanced area to a new balance area
and
that's when the move happens so balance
area
one to balance area two right you see
how the market
goes sideways here right market was
going a little sideways here
then it's gone sideways here you know
based on this order flow
there's no signal but usually when a
market is going sideways
that's also a sign of balance there's a
lot of different signs of
of balance happening in the market
there's no one one thing
in the market that says um you know this
is what balance is period and
you know you have to accept it but um
it's a little hard to explain
in that sense um james i wrote an
indicator
for the limit book and delta okay yeah
tell me more about it you'll send me an
email
can you let's see this other question
here antonius
are the indicators kws are the
indicators painted at bar
close well no
um there's
okay there's the trade entry signal and
there's not the trade entry signal if
you have the trade
entry signal turned on all right that's
this right here
right in this case it's turned off as
soon as
this bar conditions are met right this
is your
short here right as soon as the
conditions are met in this bar
then it's
it will signal right as as this bar is
forming
right it can change it could not change
right conditions can be met
it could come to not met all right but
once the bar closes then it won't change
once it's there it's there okay now
that's with the trade entry signal
off if you have the trade entry signal
on
okay let me just turn it on here real
quick i have also the zones off
or i'll tell you what let me
i'll just use this example here okay so
for example
this zone is telling me there's a trade
you know conditions are met
for the trade signal now it's not
printing the actual
entry until the next bar once the next
bar moves once that next bar moves
as long as it moves by two ticks over
the next two bars it's going to print
even if it even if that bar reverses and
closes down 10 points it's still going
to be there
okay so that won't print if you have the
trade
entry signal off
right it would just as soon as this bar
right here gives me the trade
entry as soon as the conditions are met
right even if you know it's a one minute
chart
30 seconds in there conditions are met
it will draw the arrow it'll draw the
zone
but if at 58 seconds the conditions
change
that it's no longer
met then the arrow will disappear
and the zone will disappear okay so it
really depends on
the setting that you're using now in
markers
there's a function there that's called
on bar close
okay and that's that was an important
feature of markers you know if you're
trying to automate the signal because
you know as the bar is going back and
forth as it's trading right
you um you know you don't want to be
taking the trade not taking the trade
takes your trade
because it can go back and forth right
but really the way i trade
all right is i've always waited for the
bar to close because
bars change right you got one minute
you're looking at a one minute bar
you don't really want to um
trade a one-minute bar but you're only
going to trade 45 seconds of it
no you got to wait for the bar to close
i always wait for the bar to close
so if i get a signal even if i know it's
there
it's forming i still wait for the bar to
close
right i'm not gonna all of a sudden
change
you know how i'm trading to because
there's a signal or not
um
let me just add another thing here one
five nine seven
two chart all right um take a look at
some more questions here
antonio says can you please explain
further the difference between
balance strength and balance points
assume balance strength is the like flow
strength yes it's it's like that
i'm not clear on balance point so i'm
looking at what it is
at looking at and why we should set it
to as opposed to one
um yeah you know it's
i had to describe it like i'm trying to
think of a analogy
um that would help you make perfect
sense of it
imagine a seesaw right we all know what
a a seesaw is
um
get a picture here make sure
okay so you know
the seesaw right you know people are
balanced on a seesaw right
simple right here right two kids on a
seesaw
imagine you're adding another person on
you know with the
the guy in the blue right yet another
person on there right and then you add
another person on
that's you know think about that you
know that's a way to describe
um sort of the balance points
you know how many times it's you know
you're sort of adding
on more and more to it you know for
example
you know or a tug of war right
we all know what a tug of war is right
you got you've got the
you know for example here right tug of
war um
there's gonna be times where it's
balanced
right four and four but there's times
where
it's not going to be balanced right you
could have let's see if i can find one
that's
not balanced here right you've got three
three and two
right so that's sort of where the
balance points come in right whether
it's
starting to go a little bit offsides by
you know
um one or you know you're adding one on
two you know sort of the
i don't say the offer side or the bid
side but you know you're adding more
pull on one side so to speak okay
so this is um because i put this because
miguel asked about you know he says he
trades a
15 97 tick chart so it's a 15
97 tick chart again you know i'm always
fascinated at the different charts
people trade because there's so many you
know everybody trades differently
all right so this is a 1597 tick chart
with the settings that i was using on my
other chart
right low volume
market normal market swing filter off
balance strength one
balance points two okay
you know it looks i think it's it's a
decent chart to trade
um you know it's not one that's moving
very fast it's not you know a
a four range chart that's moving very
fast or
you know i've seen people try and trade
a 233 tick chart and then they come to
how's it moving too fast well yeah it's
moving too fast because you're on such a
short range chart
um but it's a nice chart and nice moves
here right obviously
you know i forget about this move at the
end of the day that was just epic but
you know during the day the main session
you know some nice moves up nice moves
down nice moves up you know a little
sideways in here
some nice move up nice moves down nice
moves down nice move up
you know how about and now in the night
session obviously
when you're dealing a tick chart right
you're getting
a lot less bars because it's going to
take you know it takes time to form this
volume because like from this high
right this is what 130 all the way just
to here
where where are we six down here is what
six
you know you had that big move down but
you know it's a lot smaller than than it
really
um looks because it's a it's a tick
based chart
right so it's not uniform in that sense
how about the day before
all right how does it look well
obviously again you got that nice late
rally
a little move down here um a little move
up there
you know this one just sort of went
sideways again this one the trade entry
signal is on that's why it's not giving
this buy or the cell
or the cell or the cell or the cell you
know there's some nice moves here
you know on the 1597 tick chart um
let's see what else we got here
questions
um about pricing it's
well right now it's it's on a special
offer um
so it's something that
is not going to get better than that
honestly
and in the future it's going to go up
um balance point i just sort of answered
that
15 range nq
okay well if i got 15
on here i got 15. this is mnq
but questions about nq so
i'm curious myself um let's give it a
second to come up here
um is there a webinar recording on the
pulse i missed it venket
yeah there is it's on youtube but
they'll
flip it over to you how to use on higher
time frames um you can be a little bit
more specific on which time frame
um stephen i'm pulling up the 15 range
chart
asks about tomorrow um yeah you know
we're going to be sending out a
email about that a little bit later um
we don't yeah it's time change you're
on your own time i've sort of figured
that out um should be answering your
question there
um what is this why can't
johnny z ask why can't you have other
indicators up when you're using this you
can
you can
so
david asks about sierra charts no i
don't use sierra charts
there's politics behind it um which i
don't really want to get into but i
don't use zero charts
and it's it's not available for sierra
charts
rbs markers plus requires doubling the
calculations on the chart as it
internally creates a duplicate indicator
with flow shifts and markers running
together
any sense on how many charts is a
reasonable limit
before ninja starts to complain
i don't know the answer to that i
haven't experienced that issue
and that's something you should ask
pablo but
it's you know what i've found
right is yeah if
computers are very cheap now right and
if you're just going to be running a
bunch of charts for testing and stuff
you can pick up you know a decent
computer for that for you know 300
you know monitors are so cheap you know
you get decent monitors for less than a
hundred dollars each
you know 24 inch 27 inch even um
you know for testing and you keep your
computer that you're going to load up a
lot of stuff different than your trading
computer
honestly if you have a trading computer
um
and you're running markers right you're
not going to be loading 20 different
charts up on it
i mean you shouldn't be i mean why load
up
the computer that you're going to be
using you know
as your go-to thing with with other
stuff that
you know you just want to sort of follow
along the market that's me
um you know i i just think that it's
it's better
to have your trading computer run as you
know if you're running markers just run
it on the markers
run it on the markets that you're going
to be trading it with
right so um i hope that answers that
question but that's more of a question
for pablo
again i just run it on a few different
markets i i don't
really load up the charts with stuff do
i need tick replay
if i only want to see live signals
um well i always run tick replay i
always enable tick replay right tick
replay
is this function right here make sure
you have that enabled that way it'll
show up on you know historical charts if
you don't have it it should show up
if you don't have tick replay enabled
sometimes people don't want to have it
enabled
because if they think it will slow down
their um computer but there's a big
difference
between ninjatrader 7 and ninjatrader 8
on how it handles data
um and the tick replay was sort of one
of their their big
upgrades that's sort of one of the
reasons why it took ninja trader seven
how many year a ninja trader eight how
many years to get to that point where
they could release it
um is that but again if you want to
streamline it
it should work honestly i haven't tested
it but it should um
basically you know because i got emails
from people saying oh it's not showing
up on historical data it only shows up
when
i load it on the chart and you know the
new data comes in so
i'm assuming that it does i honestly i
haven't tested it but
um based on sort of the feedback that i
got on people that didn't have tick
replay enabled is that it does work
um what stop would i have if i trade
e-mini's well again it depends on your
risk
i use wider stops especially now in
these market environments
got to realize the average rotation in
the e-minis is like about four points
for
four and a half points and if you're
within that rotation
you can sort of get stopped out pretty
easily right you want to have
your stop at a point where
it's just not easily elected in sort of
the normal rotation for the market um
bowmy asks yeah if you haven't traded
futures and you're looking for a broker
again i i don't like to recommend
brokers but
you just go if you're using ninjatrader
use ninjatrader brokerage
um simple
dx rob asks about uh executing via
footprint chart you know if you're
running markers
right you could run markers it'll run on
the footprint chart as well as whatever
thing you load it with right if you're
using markers with the footprint chart
it'll still execute um then you just
manage the trade right so you can see
here i got overflows trader i got the
flow shifts on there
i don't have uh i didn't start up
markers right this is the markers in
here
all right so it'd be marker you just got
to add it on there
and yeah it i manage it from the
footprint chart
i manage all my trades from the
um uh what was that nq
right then question was about the nq15
range chart
yeah this is the 15 range chart on in
queue
obviously you know you get some very
sharp moves
but again you know i i can't trade an nq
chart on a range based chart i just
i just don't have the stomach for it it
just moves too fast for me
um you know even on a on a minute-based
chart is too fast for me when i
when i think oh you know what i got this
nq solved i
i i try to get into these periods where
i say i'm going to straight in queue
or not even in q m and q rather i traded
on a 30 second chart
um that's just me right that's just me
um what was the green and red line at
the bottom
of the black background on the e-mini
chart
i'm not sure what the question was about
uh what was the green and red line
on the bottom
of the black background e mini chart i
don't i don't use black backgrounds
uh all my charts i changed to white i
just find it easier on my eyes
so i'm not sure like these lines here
this is the low of the day this would be
the
opening price up here the green one up
at the top is the high of the day
and that's just a simple ninjatrader
indicator right you scroll down in here
it's called the what is it current day
open high low close
right that's this you could actually
even put the previous days on here
um prior day open high low close right
it's just nice to have a reference of
you know hey are we making new lows or
are we making new highs
or on days that are going sideways are
we just rotating around the opening
price
okay um
and
okay uh let's see here there are quite a
few order flow indicators you have
well again you know it depends on your
trading style
okay um you know i got
there's different indicators for
different purposes all right if you're
looking for a momentum
based interest because you know momentum
based trading is accounts for
most people are they don't realize it
but most people are
momentum-based traders um you know so i
got indicators for that then i have
people that like to trade
sport or resistance right that would be
something like the turns
okay or you know market strength or
market weakness
right that's that's another way people
trade so there's different indicators
that read different things
um antonius asks you know he's looking
to add another market he's thinking of
crude oil crude oil is a nice market
you know wheat is okay but it
it's wheat and 6e you know
if you had a choice between crude oil
wheat and euro currency i would choose
crude oil a minute is fine 30 seconds is
a little quick but um
you know maybe if crude starts rallying
up to 100 bucks you know
you might want to go to a 30-second
chart because it's gonna get a little
bit more volatile up there but um you
know
where it is now you know one minute
chart is comfortable
um okay can you trade
order flow you know on a 15-minute or 30
minute chart
not really honestly it's um
you know order flow right you're
basically
trading the freshness of the information
okay so if you're on a 30 minute chart
and
you you see something that happened
earlier
then yeah it sort of lost its efficiency
right and so you know if i was trading
like this is a one minute chart
okay so you know if i trade change it to
um you know just a 15-minute chart
all right you got to understand right
i'm looking for what's happening right
now in the market right i don't even
know if there's going to be any signals
on this
15-minute chart because so much can
happen in 15 minutes
or 30 minutes right so you know yeah are
there signals
there's some signals there's a cell here
there's a buy here there's a buy here
you know it's just one of those things
where you know it could have happened
very chances are right like this signal
here
okay it probably happened very
early as a 15-minute chart maybe the
first three minutes
okay then you got to wait the next 12
minutes
right before taking the trade now again
you know i i know some people that will
trade a 15-minute chart and as soon as
the conditions are met you know try and
scalp
intra bar you write a few ticks like
here right like in this bar
or in this bar but honestly
you're really trying to trade the
freshness of the information
okay
larry okay larry um you know what i saw
your email
larry about the next level courses
let me double check because you know
honestly you're the only one that's had
that problem
um but i'll double check on
oh you're asking if they're downloaded
no they're not downloadable i mean i
could go in there and
change the setting so they're
downloadable but um
yeah i'll do that after this
presentation because you know we
the next level overflow course which i
released earlier
in march um all my other courses
the videos have been downloadable but
this one i don't think the settings were
set to
download the videos but you know i could
go in there and set it
um it's probably just
a couple clicks on my end but i'll take
a look at that um would markers work
with fast signals yes
um yeah markers does work with fast
signals that's what uh
that's what i use i'm gonna talk about
that tomorrow i'm in london uk
is london session good volume trade yes
it is for most markets it is i mean
volume really picks up
um during the london session
right i mean it's not as good obviously
the volume is not as the same as
during the us session when europe and
the us cash markets are open but you
know it trades good volume
um johnny asked you trade lower time
frame say 15 seconds
i tried to and
problem with going down to 15 seconds
is
if you got any sort of latency all right
it's it's not going to be very good for
you
um it's one thing if you're
you got one of those you got a server
that's got you know
um it's pinging it like two milliseconds
and you can put something like markers
on there and
you know maybe take advantage of it but
you know for for most of us
if you're trying to point and click your
reaction times too slow
anyway it
and sometimes i noticed with when the
market is moving fast
ninjatrader because the data comes out
so
there's so much volume going through
imagine it's like a
funnel right you're trying to squeeze
all that volume through to get something
out the other end
it just seems that you know you get into
a trade then you stopped out
even before you know literally a second
later
a 15 second chart is is pretty quick
cause i've even looked at trading five
second charts
but you really need to have um
get the latency down basically to to do
it and honestly the ninjatrader is
probably not the best platform for that
there's other platforms obviously that
are much more expensive that you
probably want to look at
but um no um
i i don't look at that much anymore
once in a while i'll take a cursory look
at a 15 second chart but for actual
trading as low as that goes
is 30 seconds out of all your indicators
for overflow which would be recommended
for extracting
three to five on es4 to eight on zb
um well again you know flow scalpers is
a terrific program
um in the equity curve you know people
have been telling me their equity curve
is
stable you know it's not erratic so
that's good i haven't gotten the
feedback from other traders yet
on flow shifts but i think it's good
obviously pulse is one of my
favorites as well because you know what
it's really
you know so often right a market is just
sort of doing nothing and then just all
of a sudden
pops right like here right markets just
do all this was
today but you know whether you know if
you're looking at it during the day
session
right you see a market just sort of
sitting there going sideways and boom it
starts to pop the momentum picks up
right that's what the pulse does right
it looks for that you know sort of
those markets where you're just sort of
sitting there waiting for something to
happen then it happens
so um you know all my tools are just
sort of
they're like my babies um you know do i
like one more than the other
well it really depends on how i'm
trading and what market i'm trading
because i can't use the pulse on some
markets because the volume is not enough
but things like e-minis or crude oil
volume is fine
um use for range volumetric along 10
minutes okay
15-minute chart please with es with
better settings
um okay hold on
well again you know a 15-minute chart
honestly i haven't looked on a 15-minute
chart
because a lot of the
you know the data right is
when you're looking at order flow you're
looking at what's happening right now
and you sort of you know when you're
looking at a 15-minute chart you're
really taking a step back
right really as far as me personally as
far out as i go
is five minutes i do look at five
minutes but um
you know other traders you know don't
um i think if you're interested in the
pulse
shoot me an email
because i got a special link for you on
the pulse blanket
um
if you don't have any of the software
which one
which one should you get first
uh well it depends do you want to learn
order flow first or you
want to start trading order flow first
you know if you want to learn overflow i
suggest
go with um order flows trader right then
you start adding on the
the indicators to sort of help you out
um see things in the order flow because
once you start seeing signals happening
whether it's in the pulse or flow
scalper or flow trader
flow shifts then you're going to
be more in tune to trying to pick up
things that are happening in the order
flow
does it work with renko um
no no because um
renko charts the way they form no it
doesn't
it's you know that you can't really back
test wrinkle charts
uh
how does full shifts compare with the
pulse okay so anyway i got this 15
minute coming up here it's taking some
time because it's a 15-minute chart it's
got to go through these calculations
um it says calculating there but i
think i got here this is flow scalper
and pulse
pulse is flow scalper is the red and
blue the smaller arrows
the big ones are pulse right the the big
purple and the light blue
i think it's called dodger blue or
something like that just sort of give
you an idea
um
but let's take off the
flow scalper
all right because the question was flow
scalper and
pulse pulse here
or sorry flow shifts in pulse at
there okay um
what did i have i was using one and two
this was off
well that's coming up here momentum
trades are trade pull back in a trend
high after a higher high higher low
or reverse in the volume drive pull back
then resumption momentum in trend
direction
ethyl scope what indicator
brian well if you're trading
momentum
i don't know because you know i i would
say either flow shifts or or pulse
probably i would probably go with pulse
if you're
trading pullbacks in a trend because
oftentimes you're going to see on a
pullback
right you know a market sort of pull
back
and then it pops up right you're sort of
looking for that momentum
so pulse is probably better in that
reset in that regards
um verge asks about the price what's the
current prices you charge for the flow
scalper
well flow shifts 369
if you get full shifts and you want to
get flow scalper
takes you to another link where you get
flow scalper at a discounted
price but only if you buy flow shifts um
venkit just thank you just send it to my
email you got my email my kit order
flows
and i'll get you that link out on the
pulse
um i saw there were instances of volume
work it's
basically is the last question okay well
anyway here's
this is the pulse here right on the
e-minis
okay it's still loading the flow shifts
all right
the has these big
yeah i set it to differentiate the um
the arrows just so you can see it
differently the the pulse is going
the pulse is this magenta in this blue
whereas the flow shifts is the
will be the red and the normal blue
um
okay antonius asks other instances you
set volatile markets on es and
times baltimore south excellent
if again you know the reason i keep
volatile markets
off really volatile markets
the whole point of that setting is for
these markets these bars that are
very big right because you know
volatility is
what is volatility right it's the market
trying to it's got to cover more ground
to to trade basically right so that's
why volatile markets you're going to see
much bigger bars
than on non so i don't keep it on on all
markets
but it's again you know
if i do have it on honestly there's not
going to be many signals if it's not a
volatile market and you can have it on
it's not going to affect it
it may just give you maybe one or two
more signals like in the e-minis
but if you have it off it's just not
going to give you those signals it's not
going to be a big night and day
difference
it's going to be very small probably
you're not even going to notice the
difference
because if there's no volatility in the
market it's not going to give you those
extra signals
so yeah if it's not definitely won't
reduce the signals
it'll give you maybe more
um but again if it's not about like i
said i keep it on on the
on ultra bonds because sometimes that
market just
volatility just you know jumps right
and you know i don't want to miss
something because i don't have that
setting on
um okay so
bowmi um i went to the nt their and
ninjatrader has ninjatrader eights right
when they released ninjatrader eight
they released their version of order
flow tools which is just a basic
footprint chart
um and maybe one or two other tools like
you could
have delta on the bottom you could have
a
book map type thing in there as well but
it's not
the indicator and their footprint is
different than mine
in the sense that
my order flows trader all right again i
don't make this about overflow
straightaway i'll talk about it just
briefly just sort of give you sort of
the the brief overview or
the order flows trader right here order
illustrator
and you can see in here there's a lot of
different settings
okay for order flows trader um
you know you can see you have delta
divergence exhaustion prints imbalance
reversals
the different types of price ladders
more pocs you know market sweeps market
weakness
um something called order flow
sequencing none of this information
is available on the ninjatrader um
order flow suite right their suite is
just this
a basic volume footprint chart
that's all okay so because i get a
question you know sometimes people ask
me oh i just bought your software but i
see a ninjatrader they have the order
flow chart well
yeah but if you just want to look at the
footprint and delta and point of control
and where the imbalances are okay that's
fine you could use that there's actually
free versions of a footprint out there
but if you want to take it further and
understand what you're looking at
you know looking for areas i think i got
a lot of the stuff turned off right here
right
if just sort of talking about
prominent points of control okay
um do i have point controls on
here i got turned off here
but um
let me just turn it on really quick just
to sort of show you what you know what a
prominent point of control is because
the question earlier was about prominent
points of control um
but anyway while that's coming up
this is flow shifts
and pulse on the same chart okay so you
see there's
not really any overlap
signals are coming in at different
places
right and why is because it's reading
different parts of
the order flow right
in this case the pulse signal came
before
the flow shift signal whereas here right
the flow shift signal came before the
pulse signal
okay so you know they're meant not to
replace each other but they sort of
complement
each other okay um
but anyway just um you know while this
chart's
coming up here right this is a prominent
point of control right here
okay right and and you know what a
prominent point of control is it's a
point of control that acts as support or
resistance right right here right
wouldn't you like to know that hey you
know what
based on the order flow there's support
here right you see how the market
rallied up okay you know that's you know
like that's not available on the
ninjatrader
um system for order flow
okay all they're giving you is just the
normal footprint chart but anyway
that's that and anyway you know we're
running on uh about
two hours um so again you know
if you're into the software you know get
it now while it's at this price because
it's going to go up later
um it's going to jump in prices at 369.
my programmer wants to put it at 497. so
this is
you know this is a great time to take
advantage of it at this price
so tom asks is there going to be a
replay yeah there will be
another replay but there will be a
there'll be a recording
i'm not sure when i'll get it up um
tonight or
maybe over the weekend so because you
know tomorrow we got that
one with um pablo let me see if i could
find a link here for tomorrow's with
with pablo because i know some people
are also interested in that so just give
me a second
here i'll get the link for tomorrow's
if you haven't joined when i i'll be
sending it out later anyway
but the link is there in the in the chat
just click on it
to join for tomorrow
um well we'll see what pablo's got for
you tomorrow me i i haven't gone over it
with him yet
um we're just sort of chatting but um
you know it's a tool
right he's got a great tool markers is
something that's
been around
for you know since you know ninjatrader
seven
and you know he's just he's a good guy
pablo is
he's very helpful i've i've talked to
him on many occasions and
um
you know it's nice that he's got a great
tool for traders that it's it looks
it's let's think with software right is
it's hard
sometimes to get used to it you know
whether it's
trading software whether it's you know
you know
video editing software or whatever um it
takes things take time to get used to
them
and you know i like that's why i like
markers because it's very simple to use
once you understand how to use it and
then that's what tomorrow is going to be
about
um is about getting it set up with
markers
um ronnie asks about bloodhound i don't
know i don't use bloodhound
i talked to the guys at bloodhound a few
years ago um
actually around the time before i made
the big switch to ninja traders
eight um 2018 um
about stuff and you know they they
they said they'd get back to me and then
we sort of just
never talked again so i don't know i do
i know i have a few users that use
bloodhound
and they tell me it does work with them
but again i don't know i don't use
bloodhound myself
i haven't used bloodhound since i was
talking to the guys at bloodhound
years ago on ninjatrader 7. so
i'm not sure i can't really answer that
question i don't give you an answer
either way
but anyway guys um i don't want to keep
you guys on much
longer um okay we uh
15-minute chart once okay let's take a
look here do i got it
did it ever come up here um
where's my 15-minute chart this one okay
again it's the 15-minute chart
yeah there's some signals but again
you know i i don't i wouldn't really
want to trade a 15-minute chart
me you know i'm different than other
people
um but you know there's some signals you
know when you're going to trade a
15-minute chart obviously i think is the
best time to trade it is during
the day session but i mean look at this
you know
on day like today right you got this bar
here
you know from six oh looks 26
you know it's a 20 point bar um
i just find it a little hard to trade
myself you know i'd i'd prefer
something that's a little bit more
manageable but i mean there's there's
moves
you know is would i trade it i mean you
might have to find some
settings i might need to adjust the
settings a little bit
um bowmi
that package doesn't is an old one
it's that package comes with
the overflows trader the pulse and the
turns
but if you're interested in that package
boom you can get it i will
swap out the turns i'll throw in the
flow shifts instead um
or the flow scalper but again you know i
that was an old
that was the old version of order flows
i just
i don't know how you found that page but
i thought i took that page down
um but anyway that
that really is the best offer but i
could switch out the indicators
for you um
ben asks what time is tomorrow's webinar
it's at 10 a.m
it's in the morning 10 a.m chicago time
pablo's in argentina so he's i think
he's in different much different time
zone than me
argentina or brazil i forget um
carlos can you put the put on the turns
um
i could but i i'm not really talking
about the turns today
um all right let me just get this back
to a one-minute chart
uh
just give me a second here um
all right i'll put the turns on here
honestly i haven't looked at the turns
on the one minute chart today turns is a
little bit different
all right there's there's actually two
settings there's for
long duration and short duration okay
long duration
it'll be things like you know one minute
chart and you can also have short
duration if you're using a very quick
but what people like you can actually
put both you can put long
and short on the same chart um i have
this set at
look back period for now i'll just turn
it off look back
just so you guys can see the signals um
i'm going to put it both long and short
yeah mommy email me here i'll put my
email there for you
there anyway let's see what comes up on
this i i didn't uh
i don't have it on this chart here so
after this turns one comes up i'll uh
i'll end it there because it's been two
hours so thanks everyone for staying on
here but you know if you're interested
to see how the turns chart looked
um stick around let's take a look
give it a second because i got both
running up there
robert
robert asks he says he didn't realize
there was a new version of order for his
trader
um yeah you know it came out back in
october for people that have
the software it's the upgrade is free so
this is
turns again i have the
trade entry signal turned on okay so
that's why you see a lot of these
signals here right here but there's no
up or down arrow if i turn off the
i'll keep the trade entry signal on um
i'm going to turn off the zones here so
zones change you to zero
it changes you to zero
you know it sort of cleans it up a
little bit
james asks
what atr minimum to use in the volatile
markets checkbox
volatile markets checkbox is really
meant for
markets that have a lot of volatility
okay so
it's got nothing to do with the atr
you're going to use
on anything else you know it's just if
you're
putting the indicator on a market that's
more volatile
then um
it's gonna take into account the extra
volatility in the market
of that market that you're trading
but anyways um yeah by
juan so here right you could see this
was today
on the turns okay right there's a cell
signal here a buy signal here a cell
signal there
cell signal there a by rather here
these cells late in the day um
this is the evening session say or
not evening but the morning session 6
30. all right some signals there
and again you know this is just the
basics
almost the basic settings
all right long and short i have the
lookback filter turned off i have the
threshold set at
0.3 which is 30
0.3 on both long and short but anyway
that's the turns again
that's a that's a presentation for
another time
uh you know if you're interested in
seeing that like email me i could put
one together
for you guys anyway guys have a great
day great night rather
and again you know hope if you're
interested you know now's the time to
pick up the indicator
go to flow shifts dot com but again you
know if you're interested in
in the replay i'll be sending it out uh
later
okay so have a great night and hopefully
i'll see you guys
some of you guys at least uh tomorrow on
tomorrow's presentation
with pablo so bye bye everyone